so jumping back to the to the money in
politics I would be wrong is if we if we
didn't mention Bernie Sanders in all
this hello
you love Bernie okay so can a 70
something year old Brooklyn Jew
socialist self-proclaimed socialist can
he actually affect this election I think
I think he can nudge it nudge it but not
effective no no no because he's gonna
he'll make a nice impact and people you
know he's I love Bernie and Bernie will
it will have his say and he would be an
excellent debater mm-hmm but Hillary
still again Hillary's gonna get the
nomination and Bernie will campaign for
her and so will Elizabeth Warren then
yeah the Democrats will come behind
Hillary the Republicans will come behind
whoever the nominee is why she's I mean
are we really gonna have a Clinton Bush
is that if you had to get know people
make like that's bad I think that would
be a good race i but didn't this way we
have with I like Jeb Bush Jeb Bush is
very intelligent I've known him a long
time yeah Hillary and Bush Hillary and
Jeb I hope would be a clean discussion
of the issues fair discussion
interesting yes I would look forward to
that yeah do you think that would be a
battle of ideas though to me what I want
to see is a battle of ideas I want to
see something like Rand Paul verse
Bernie where it's really two people one
a libertarian the other one a socialist
who really have ideas and really let's
have an actual engagement of ideas
versus hip you know Jeb and Hillary we
know what it is we know Erika never
never accept Rand Paul versus Bernie
Sanders that would be an independent
would move in and win that